[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen Bal and uh Ryan's not here
again for the second week he's uh
hanging out with his dad and playing
some music and we miss him but we also
have Bryce here Bryce welcome hi thanks
thanks for all your hard work man of
course you see my face more than anybody
I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry we got a great
guest for you this week boy is it a
really great guest if you're here good
episode it is if you're here for alen
richen um listen I hope if you love it
enough you'll say I'm going to give this
podcast a chance this is a little
podcast that with the patrons who
support the podcast patron.com inside of
you our loyal listeners uh have kept
this podcast afloat and um if you like
this episode I encourage you to just
subscribe and listen that's if I'm
giving you some entertainment and you
like it give it a chance and if in some
way you're here for Allan and you didn't
hear his first appearance listen after
cuz that's another one of the best
episodes it really is it really is in
this episode I didn't think it could be
any better and he gets into some really
important things that I was blown away
by that makes me put bipolar in uh it
puts it in a different perspective
because it really makes it was easily
understood he made it put it in layman's
terms he uses a word like um it
shouldn't be called bipolar it should be
called unipolar MH and I just found it
really interesting um how describes it
yeah it was interesting hearing him talk
about it with his family Dynamic too
because he's not just a guy with bipolar
he's also a father and a husband it's
interesting absolutely um if you want to
follow us which is important at inside
podcast on Facebook and Instagram at
inside pod on the Twitter and you can
watch these episodes on YouTube for the
time being and uh I encourage you again
to join patreon and support the podcast
there's so many perks I write you little
messages I send packages of things
there's zooms there's there's uh YouTube
lives there's uh with me where you ask
questions for me uh you get to ask
questions on [__] talking to guests you
get your name shouted out on each
episode lot of perks and you help out
the show I figure if you're getting Hulu
for $499 you could be a patron yep right
for whatever 99 not 14.99 $4.99 boy with
that help um but there's all different
patrons so whatever you can do or just
listen honestly
um great episode and uh you can go to my
link tree lastly before we get into this
episode on Instagram atth Michel
rosenbom and it has everything my Cameo
if you want to do Cameo if you want to
see what cons I'm going to my live
podcast with Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad
Jessica Jones be in apartment 23 she's
my guest at a live podcast at the Regent
Theater January 24th 730 p.m. or 7 p.m.
look at it on the Instagram link and
there's a meet and greet with uh me and
Kristen and and so much more so get
tickets it will eventually s sell out
I'm
hoping um and that's that and the inside
of you online store has a bunch of
groovy stuff too so without further Ado
let's just get into it let's get inside
of Allan richson it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen
[Music]
B
inside of you with Michael rosenbom was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience first of all it's like happy
birthday your birthday is in a couple
days here oh yeah that's right oh thanks
oh that's that's sweet of you 40 years
old I be 41 41 so I'm 10 years older
than you a little over than 10 years
gross you're so [__] handsome I mean
do you do you feel 41 or do you still
feel like you're like in your 20s or 30s
you know what no dude um
I've aged so much life
has not not not necess I mean definitely
you know I'm I'm
um I'm I'm I'm settling into a body that
doesn't do things like it used to in
fact I just put a post up on Instagram
about a run that I went on where I was
really wrestling with sort of the U just
just being content with what I'm able to
do these days you know and part of that
is because of age but part of it is
because of the size that I'm at now you
know I used to run a lot you know know
but for a guy who in my 20s and early
30s really I would go rip like 13 Mile
runs just for the fun of it um around
the hills of LA and like run really
quick clips I can't do that kind of
stuff anymore like now it takes a lot of
effort for me to to to run four or five
miles and it's painful and it leaves me
sore for a couple days and you know um
that's age you know but there's also you
know there's also the life experience
that I've had and there's been so much
of it um the work the jobs that I've had
where life has taken me um the the
problems that um I faced at home and uh
at work and it's um it's all helped me
really settle into this place where I'm
like you know what I'm a middle-aged man
now and we've got to we've got to learn
to take things slow we've got to learn
to accept other
people's other people's best and that
might be average you know um it's a
conversation I have with my psychiatrist
all the time um average is hard average
is hard and I feel like I've been given
a motor that that burns above average
like at a speed that's too much for most
people to handle um and a m that kind of
races at a pace that's like a lot faster
and so it's hard to slow down for people
sometimes you know and go like okay let
me let them figure this out I've already
thought about this um and uh uh learning
you know like learning to to be content
and grateful for the gifts that I have
and accept just all the people in my
life and how different and diverse they
are it's just that that is where you
know I feel like a middle-aged man now
well I'm all of this I'm 51 this one
Comedian says uh I think I've said this
before but he says you know uh they say
when they say 30 is the new 20 they say
40 40 is the new 30 but when you 50 you
just 50 no nothing new about that [__]
only
you wear it real well man wear it really
well well look this is a this is
happening the day after Thanksgiving so
I am s I'm like in a cloud like all the
food and my friend made jell shots and I
had some pot taffies and I just had fun
and I Karaoke I so it is the so 50 is
the new 20 there really we now it's
coming full circle well 50 might be the
new 20 last night but the day after is
50 is the new 80 because that's how I
feel I feel like every like my neck my
back wasn't there a song My Neck My Back
Back we can't say yeah I didn't say it I
didn't say it kids watch but you said
something uh important a second ago you
just said you know in layman's terms it
was something like uh you just do what
you can you do your best you don't you
don't need to push yourself if you're in
pain like you know I just that's what I
got from it I'm like hey whatever I you
said like whatever you can do is what
you do it's not about oh I have to be
this guy I have to be able to run 13
miles it's like hey if it's a half a
mile a mile I'm doing it I'm feeling
something I'm going to go back I'm going
to home I'm going to rest I'm going to
ice I'm gonna do whatever it takes to
take care of yourself I mean I'm I'm I'm
guessing that's what you do because you
said something with your size yeah no
totally yes yes I mean there's like you
know people talk about the Power of Now
all the time right I mean we've got the
eart toes of the world
um shouting from the rooftops that we
should focus on the now right well what
is the now it's meeting ourselves where
we are in that moment and there we have
to bring some compassion for ourselves
there's a lot of love in being willing
to meet ourselves where we are and I you
know for for the longest time uh I would
punish myself with the kind of abuse um
like even in the gym where I go like if
I die on this treadmill I've won that
was my mental philosophy working out if
I die doing this workout I I I beat the
game like I won and that's there's no
love in that there's no love in that so
so we've got to find the F line between
pushing ourselves to be better tomorrow
than we are today but we can get there
by finding compassion for who we are and
meeting ourselves at our best where we
are right now you know so um yeah that's
important and and where I'm at right now
physically you know I'm I'm wearing a
lot of weight for the roll of Reacher
240 wait 240 well 240 I mean I'm
probably actually you know I've been
working out pretty hard I'm probably 245
now but um um a little heavier now but
yeah I'm I'm that's a lot of weight you
know so like for me to be running around
the hills um not
easy what what hurts what a what a big
guys uh you know you got a lot of these
guys like my my friend Dave Bautista and
you got Jason Mamoa and you got because
I really put you on that you're on that
tier to me you're like uh you're super
talented and your comedic timing is
amazing so I'm like you know and I want
to get into that I want to get into your
trajectory and all that but in terms of
like your size like is it really hard on
certain parts of your body to be that
big um I think it's hard on the heart
you know I mean um think about like so
there's a couple things that I start to
feel it's um the lung capacity feels
like I just can't keep up you know um
like if I I did Sprints this morning and
it's just amazing how quick I'm
like like really winded and it did
wasn't always like that but I'm trying
to get a lot of oxygen to a lot of
muscles but uh you know I weigh 240
pounds and I'm you know if I'm climbing
there's some hills out here where I am
where I'll I'll run these Hills if I'm
climbing up a hill it's a little bit
like doing lunges for 20 minutes
straight I mean throw for most people
throw 280 on your shoulders and do 20
minutes of lunges your muscles are going
to explode so I feel like when I'm
running I start to feel my muscles
aching just because it's like it's just
pushing a lot of weight one one one step
at a time you know without without
breaking and you you know you feel that
so it's tough It's you got to make
adjustments when you're you're wearing
this kind of size and some of the guys
you mentioned like mimo and all them you
know um you know he's got his out you
know he's like a world class rock
climber you know so he's there's some
activities that he does like insane like
a a spider monkey um uh you know but I
don't think he's out there
running you know so I've got to make
some you know we got to make adjustments
for that kind of thing do you think that
the there's a time in your life where
you'll sort of I mean because to
maintain that and a lot of times you
look at these guys and they if they ever
stop working out well they're probably
gonna be
fat right so I had a have you ever had a
dexa
scan uh no what is that do you know what
that do you have you aexa scan is um a
fancy new scan um a little bit like it's
kind of like laying in an MRI machine
kind ofo I did pruvo where a body scan a
body scan right and it'll tell you your
muscular composition your body fat
composition it tells you like like
you'll know all your sizes measurements
but you'll also get your caloric uh your
caloric values so you're going to know
exactly what you need to maintain your
size if you want to gain weight how you
know so for me I'm just shy of 4,000
calories a day just to maintain just to
maintain so um so if I if I stop working
out for a little bit and I'm still on
that you know I trained my body to eat
4,000 calories a day it would take me
about three weeks to blow up you know um
so it does take a lot of consistency I
work out five days a week you know it's
got to be a lifestyle but what we talked
about last time I I think I mentioned
last time we spoke which by the way I'm
so grateful to have been a part of this
once before yeah um I have so many
people sto me um not about Reacher not
about fad from Blue Mountain State which
I get a lot of uh stop me just for the
conversation that we had together on
your podcast um me too and I think it
really touched a lot of lives and uh I
just think it's uh you know again just
to be I'm grateful for what you do um
thank you and grateful to be here again
but um but the last time we talked I
think that I think I mentioned that I
had just started taking
testosterone was that true I I think so
I can't remember exactly but maybe yeah
yeah so I had just started so after
season one I broken my body um trying to
build it up and and trying to carry the
schedule uh that we had and uh I had a
broken shoulder and I was taking a a you
know an end a very powerful ID for that
and that all of it together collectively
just killed my testosterone so I had to
get on testosterone because my blood
levels were
non-existent since then I still take
testosterone it has made life so much
easier for me in my 40s to do the things
that I need to do for my job like keep
weight on at 240 pounds of like solid
muscle um so that's a big part of the
secret and I'm not going to lie about
that you know I want people to know
because I want people in their 40s 30
late 30s early 40s to know this is a
legitimate opportunity for us like we
should it's a like a cheat code but this
is your body's you know this is your
your body's own material so just help it
you know what I mean this is good stuff
you know working with the doctor get
your blood if your blood levels are fine
great you don't need it um you know
there are side effects to be you know
it's hard on some of the organs if you
um aren't careful what's a good level
what's a good level of testosterone like
there's normal levels levels like up to
like 1,00 or whatever like what is yeah
what I think the numbers changed I I
understand the way I understand it the
numbers have evolved down so I think it
used to be between like 500 and 2,000
was like healthy levels I think it
shrunk a lot I think now if you're if
you're up like in the 1500 range you're
really high but I think you want to be
some some I I think you want to be
somewhere between like 500 and a th000
and I'm sure some people will correct me
and I hope so um and uh so we stay right
at the upper end of that scale right um
uh you know with my doctor but it's um
it's it's it's made it so I don't have
to put so much wear and tear on myself
um in order to grow or develop or
maintain you know so it's um that's
that's a big part of it yeah and I want
to add to the uh the conversation that
we had because it was unexpected it was
one of those things where you and I are
talking in the first conversation and
then you open up about how you know you
almost tried to end your life and I was
shocked taken aback and also I felt this
wave of just
appreciation admiration and boy did
people come up to me as well and tell me
how just how much they were affected by
it and a lot of people don't open up and
I and I it's not a prerequisite for to
come on the podcast that you have to
just get you know throw everything out
but you're that kind of guy you're that
you know since I've known you you're
just sort of this is this is me and I'm
flawed and uh you know we all make
mistakes and we all have dark times in
our lives but I got through
it inside of is brought to you by rocket
money I don't know why everybody doesn't
have this price if you don't have this
app I don't know what to do with you you
want to save money get Rocket money how
many of us have subscriptions that we
get for one show and then we forget to
cancel our subscription to fulu or
whatever it is and then we're like oh my
gosh I just got charged 70 bucks for the
last five months I've been paying fulu
for like a year now it's unbelievable
and you can't get reimbursed for that
they won't they're not going to you know
rocket money is going to save you it's
going to save you so much money um and
it's hard it's hard to to save money
these days let alone waste money and
Rocket money is there rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps lower
your bills rocket money has over 5
million users and has helped saved its
members an average of
$720 a year yeah with 500 million in
cancelled
subscriptions they'll even try to get
you a refund for the last couple of
months of wasted money and negotiate to
lower your bills for you on
fulu correct whoa but they will then
negotiate to lower your bills by up to
20% all you have to do is take a picture
of your bill and Rocket money takes care
of the rest stop wasting money on things
you don't use cancel your unwanted
subscriptions by going to Rocket
money.com inside rocket
money.com inside inside of you is
brought to you by neurohacker this
qualia cellytic is just fabulous Bryce I
uh you know when a product comes along
that you actually see a difference and
you can talk about it and be honest
about it um I've talked about this uh
look if you haven't heard about caletics
yet it's a class of ingredients
discovered less than 10 years ago and
they're being called one of the biggest
discoveries of our time for helping to
promote healthy aging and helping to
enhance your physical prime now your
life goals in your career and Beyond
require
productivity but let's be honest the
aging process is not our friend when it
comes to endless energy and productivity
and that's why I use qua cellytic if
someone would have told me that there
are science-backed ingredients that
could help me feel 15 years younger in a
matter of months well I wouldn't have
believed it then I tried Quia cytic um
it's funny because I talk about this but
it's something that I wasn't even aware
that they were a sponsor and I was
taking I was like this stuff really
works and then when they became a
sponsor I was like wait a minute oh this
is great um it's something that really
just I have a I feel like I'm I'm
clear-minded um you know it's it's
something that you just take two days a
month which is which is pretty awesome
you don't have to do this every day it's
two days a month the formula is non-GMO
vegan gluten-free the ingredients are
meant to complement one another
factoring the combined effect of all
ingredients together and it has a 100
day money back guarante that's crazy it
is crazy they just believe in this
product so much and so do I um but I I
do have higher energies energy levels I
I do feel younger um I'm absolutely more
productive and enthusiastic and uh you
know somebody who's had a lot of back
surgeries here I'm definitely less achy
less pains I just feel an overall
difference and when I don't take it I
notice a bigger difference in the
negative way so this is really amazing
help resist aging at the cellular level
try quaa cytic go to neurohacker
docomo inside at checkout for an
additional 15% off these statements have
not been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
neurohacker dcom inside for an extra 15%
off your purchase thanks to neurohacker
for sponsoring today's video
I got through it and you you speak so
openly about it that I you know when
people ask me what's your favorite
podcast episode this has got to be up
there I've done over 300 and I'm like
this is this is certainly you know which
shows just shows how much pain we're all
in right like how much we all suffer to
figure out how to make this work you
know um or how to um you know create the
least amount of trouble for for other
people or however we go about thinking
about our escapism our wishes our
fantasies our sins like whatever it is
that we get into um you know we're all
really struggling to figure it out and
to to withhold the truth about what I've
experienced I think would be living a
huge lie and I I think we'd be missing
the entire purpose of life which is for
us to figure out how to enjoy this
together you know um uh to connect with
one another and that's not my like
natural disposition like I'm I'm I'm
like a really reserved person in life
you know and it's odd because I you go
like well you chose a career where you
like way out front in front of a lot of
people but that I was just an
opportunity to go like oh I really do
enjoy I really love what I do I love
being on set in front of the camera
figuring out how to master this
character or story I could completely do
it in isolation if I could take care of
my family with a living I could do it in
isolation where nobody sees it and I'd
be just as happy um I don't like the
fame the fame aspect is super toxic man
um and so I don't you know I don't like
that but but I will use it if it will
bring us closer together if it will help
us heal if it will help us feel safe or
like understood or less alone and I
think you know I don't want to talk
about it any more than anybody else does
but like I have to make myself
uncomfortable and go there um because
nobody's going to connect with me over
like money be like you know like look at
how much money I'm making dude I'm doing
so good like everything's so great I got
a family I got this I just bought a PS5
like nobody nobody's GNA be like I feel
so
seen that's not what we connect we
connect through our pain truly if we
really want to we have to connect
through our pain and no one's going to
start that conversation for us we have
to be the one to start it in our
personal lives we have to be willing to
have deeper conversations where we go
you know man I've been through some
really tough times here's what I've
learned and then then somebody goes me
too that's where that's where that's
where the the you know We crave the Deep
connection people talk all the time
about we're so torn apart we're so
divided our country will never be the
same man it starts with us in these
little conversations that are honest
yeah you know um last night and this is
this is uh air airing a little later but
it was Thanksgiving and I told you that
but it was the first time I always every
year we go around and say what we're
thankful
for
and I couldn't there was 20 27 28 people
over my house and we in the back and I
said everybody come on and it was hard
to gather them and they're like no no
come on we're doing this we do this
every year we're gonna do it we're gonna
be thankful you know Farley asked and I
Farley and I had everybody go around and
talk and I I never do this but I went to
each person and said what I'm thankful
for I never done that but everyone went
we went
around and at least least five people
opened up and were crying which a lot of
people start crying about you know they
just you know my friend Alex lost her
dad recently um you know there was all
these sto and it was just so beautiful
to see because everybody's like oh I
just want to say I'm thankful for this
and thanks thanks Michael for being here
it just
felt it felt real it felt every just
vulnerable and raw and as much fun as we
were having and all these things it was
just a a great moment and I love to see
when people can be so uh so just true
not only to themselves but in front of
others and it was a beautiful thing so
it takes so much courage it takes so
much bravery um to to discuss even the
simplest uh pains um uh and you leave
feeling like you know them better right
like now you really know them you know
another thing that's behind a lot of
their motives to be kind you know to be
quick witted uh to be short-tempered
whatever it is like you know once we
start to know people's pain we really
start to know them and now we can
understand and now empathy can enter in
and all of it all of it yeah but um you
know I think it's our responsibility to
be like you did to Foster that
conversation you know yeah it was
awesome it was truly awesome you know
good for you I want to we can get into
all this stuff again but um so your
publicist sent me the screener for
Reacher and I love the first season and
I love the world that it's in and it's
like and I'm not I mean I want to toot
your horn
because that didn't sound right that
didn't sound right fine I'm with you
can you are the glue everyone around you
is all great but like it's so fun to
watch you I'm waiting for your little
smart ass remarks your little your
little subtle things little but like
even in this first episode which airs
December 10th on Amazon is that right uh
December 15th I 15th December 15th okay
um and you don't need to tell people to
watch it because they're going to watch
it um I just felt like another gripping
story you're watching you're watching it
all come together and there's this twist
at the end where you're just like going
oh now I know we're in store for the
rest of the season and it's and by the
way my friend Joe's out there with my
dogs helping me out today and he's also
a fan so it's like it's pretty cool when
around me all my friends are fans of
this show but it's you it's like it's
like this is like the perfect role for
you and it's you're the badass you have
heart you're a Vigilant I mean you do
you do good things like you know the old
woman at the or the woman at the uh the
cash the ATM and it's there's a weird
thing because you're not being too to
sappy you're too you're doing something
like that's right that you know it's
right you're taking care of business but
you're still in your
own it's I I really love your character
I think it's so good and that's why when
I said Jason MIM Mo and da
Batista you you can be doing all the
things that they're doing you you you
will have the movie career because you
have that and that's a charm and that's
something I believe that's innate and
something that you just just have that
you've always had inside of you but now
you've gotten to do a role where you're
not just the [__] you know this guy
you're doing this now you're playing a a
dynamic character that you just shine
and you don't even have it seems like
you're not even trying which I love
you're not overdoing it which could
easily be done and turn viewers off your
character stays I mean he's also you
know he's it's a dangerous character
because um uh he's he's so stoic in his
own head uh you know his mind working
like a computer all the time um and he's
so kind of
emotionally unavailable compared to most
most human beings it could leave I mean
my big fear was that I would not be able
to create an interesting character for
the screen that people would be like
bored out of their mind watching the
show because this guy's not charismatic
or interesting enough because there's on
physically externally there's not a lot
going on until there's just until
there's an explosion of action that we
kind of look forward to but really he's
a rather still character um e externally
and uh I'm glad to hear you say that you
enjoy watching him so much you feel
those layers that are going on you know
but
um yeah it's uh it really is a dream
role um and it's one of those that I
just uh sometimes I do sit back and
think like I am so lucky um that this
role found me and I get to play a role I
feel like I was truly born to play you
know um there are others you know
there's a lot of scripts that we're a
part of attached to right now that are
characters nothing like Reacher that I
cannot wait to explore and showcase um
but this this one I think will always be
like you know just um the Cornerstone of
of um my my career yeah and I think that
um I I know for a fact that we talked
about you know your you just mentioned
it your shoulder you were exhausted you
were doing all you were stressed out of
your mind the first season and it was
just like I I remember talking to you at
a con or something you're like dude I
don't I don't know if I could I don't
know if I could do this man I don't know
if I could do that I mean this is genely
like holy [__] uh what changed from the
first season to sex sex season second
season where yeah the Sex season was a
lot more laid-back yeah a little more
sexy this show is sponsored by better
help better help online therapy do not
fast forward because this is something
that truly helps so many people around
the world so many of my friends um you
hear the guests how many guests talk
about therapy and it's just it's amazing
and a lot of people I talk about how you
know a family member who you know no one
will understand me no one knows what
I've been through well that's not true
there's so many people that do know what
you're going through and and um they've
seen it all and therapy really truly
helps it helps me and whether or not
your family gives gifts during the
holidays you can always give yourself
the gift of a healthier you whether by
starting therapy going easier on
yourself in tough moments or treating
yourself to a day of complete rest
remember to give yourself some love this
holiday season this time of year can be
a lot it's hectic it's stressful it's
really easy to forget to take time for
yourself but you deserve it as much as
your loved ones do and it's super
convenient with better help it's
entirely online and designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule even during the holidays just
fill out a brief questionnaire this
thing takes no time at all to get
matched with the licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge so if you're not
vibing with your therapist don't think
oh it's not working no just switch to
another therapist and feel the Vibes
feel good about who you're talking to
you feel uh comfortable and you will
find that with better help in the season
of giving give yourself what you need
with better help visit better help
help.com insid toay to get 10% off your
first month that's better help
hp.com inside inside of you is brought
to you by discover if you like using
debit over credit don't you think it's
time you also get rewarded well now you
can with discover cashback debit it's a
checking account that rewards everyone
with cash back on everyday purchases
plus there are no fees period we're
talking date nights thrifting the latest
trends nights out with your friends and
it's now earning you cash back with
discover cashback debit check out
eligibility in terms at discover.com
slashback debit Discover Bank member
FDIC but what changed in the second
season where
um a a lot a lot I mean look we you know
we I have a great team around me and you
know you mention uh like you mentioned
really enjoying the story and the show
and the character and his mannerisms and
that like the witty like smartass remark
he makes that kind of you just you're
waiting for him to tell his honest truth
and the th those things that you're
enjoying you're really enjoying the
minds of uh my the creative team that's
around me um Nick santor the showrunner
who does an unbelievable job bringing
the reacher to life that we know and
loveing the books um and it's difficult
adapting that to TV and he knows just
how to do it and I'm fed by him um you
know and Don Granger at Sky Dan and Dana
Goldberg at Sky Dan all you know all the
executive partners that are like really
making sure we're picking the right
books and all the you know adapting it
well for TV Sam Hill our producing
director um you know there are people
around us that people cannot appreciate
the way that I appreciate them that are
making Reacher what it is for people to
enjoy
um I that has to be said um so there's
there's that um but we all collectively
have figured out things that worked and
didn't work about the first season and
have pivoted and um and also the
pressure of the season um going into
season one where everybody was
like let me whisper to you what Reacher
would do in this moment and then get me
getting that from 20 people at every
every take it was exhausting frustrating
and and it was necessary um but I don't
have that because once the season came
out everybody goes we found it
and now there's this like just this
level of enjoyment you know where where
um that that pressure is gone and now
it's sort of like we get to enjoy seeing
what Reacher would do in these
situations as we make this thing
together um that the pressure of like
are you Reacher are we are we telling
are are we show showcasing the Right
image for Reacher the tone the
personality The Voice the mannerisms
like are we making Reacher come to life
on screen is um has been solved you know
we're confidently settled into who this
is and I understand this character now
and what you know so it's it's taken
it's just made it a really enjoyable
process now well it seems like a lot of
the stress like you just said came from
uncertainty it came from did you go home
at night sometimes and going I just I
don't know if it's I'm giving them what
they want I don't know if this is the
guy I don't know what I'm did you carry
a lot of the stress a lot of the the
weight on you no pun intended man I
always felt like at the end of the day
cuz I I worked so hard people have no
idea dude I I set up entirely new
methods for how I can learn scenes so
that I could learn everybody's line
including mine so I would learn not just
my lines I would learn everybody else's
and by knowing the scene that well it
gave me the opportunity to have 20
people tell me how they want me to do
the scene and to Pivot and do it that
way so I left so many options on the
table season one there was no question
about about like did I get the right
Reacher I knew there was some version of
Reacher there you just had take your
pick you know and that that came from
that that came from the work so it
wasn't you know it wasn't so much that
it was just
um uh
just uh just the sheer the workload that
it took to uh to to be able to honor
that that necessity you know was um it
was it was a lot it was a lot um and uh
that part of the process is is gone now
you know so now I can approach much more
like any other project or a film you
know and that's um it just helps you
know yeah what about what about the
family like your family you've got you
still live in Florida uh no I just stld
my place in Florida yeah all right so
you're
gone yeah gone from Florida I mean look
here's the thing I um since Reacher came
out there was there was this moment you
know I I I I I fought really hard for
Reacher it took months and months and
months to convince everybody that I was
the
guy it you know I was passed on the
first time I think I mentioned to you
maybe last I was passed on in the very
beginning beginning of the process um
like everybody was and I think that was
because I'm 63 Reacher 65 I think they
they were trying to you know everybody's
trying to get a super authentic version
of Reacher on screen and um so there's
always kind of an asteris in my mind you
know um when it comes to this role uh
but I had to really fight for that and
now now that we're in it
um it's explod like the career's
exploded because of uh
what happened after reer aired
beforehand we were waiting the whole
town was like let's see what happens
when it airs there was months of Silence
nobody was picking up the phone there
was no conversations about scripts um it
it aired and within 48 hours I had 20
offers on my desk from the biggest
producers and studios in town and it
hasn't slowed up I mean it's still like
every day we're getting phone calls from
some of the the most legendary people
you can imagine give me one give me one
so I did a movie okay so I did a movie
with Jerry Jerry B Brook armer produced
uh guy Richie directed called Ministry
of un gentlemanly Warfare this was a
movie I did for Lionsgate domestic and
Amazon international um so some partners
that I knew and have relationships with
on this and some some new relationships
formed um this movie is so good you
can't I cannot believe this movie is so
fun there's nothing like it it's like
guy Richie at his best based on a true
story there World War Two uh Heroes who
um uh were essentially the first uh
Special Ops
um it's a it's a tolden guy Richie style
wow um it's super
cool um I just went into that feeling
very lucky to be a part of this cast you
know Henry caval and Alex peder and you
know Henry just a great amazing cast
um Jerry bromer calls because he saw the
movie just a few days ago he saw he saw
a cut of the film and um you know he
said we have to do um we have to do
something together like with you out
front come on I know Jerry a long time
I'm buddies with him name drop but like
you like Jerry for Jerry to call someone
to call an do you know how like did like
like like a high adventure like nobody
does high adventure better than this guy
no and and uh and it's it's the toughest
genre to make I think and um you know
for him to call U you know one of the
most legendary producers of all time you
know you get those kind of calls it's
like there's just no better feeling you
know um and and it's it's because of
Reacher that those kind of call are
coming in I wouldn't have done that job
if I my career had been fueled by
Reacher and Jerry is like the kind of
guy he's so softspoken he's so
intimidating but such a sweet guy but
he's just like and you when you meet him
I remember the first time because I I
you know I had this I was in this Hockey
League I'm still in the hockey league
and it was Jerry bookheimer hockey
league on Sunday nights and I've done it
for 25 years and and it's producers and
actors and like you know kef for
southernland and a bunch of you know and
then Pro players would play and it was
competitive and fun you know the first
time I go Jerry hey thanks happen me he
was like you he just nodded and then few
months later be like hey Jerry he's like
how are you and then a year later two
years three years was like hey
Michael he knows my name four years hey
Michael uh you know conversations and
slowly I built this little friendship
with Jerry and you know where we' go he
go uh you know if you'd like to fly with
us in my private jet to Vegas uh like
yeah he goes would you see the event and
so like I'm like for Jerry to call
you you guys don't understand Jerry
brookheimer is not someone who just
throws out compliments and throws out
like for him say and I want to work with
you we're going to do something else
we're gonna I mean good for you good for
you oh thanks man thanks I think that's
an awes I'm so happy because I know how
hard you worked I mean I saw all the
shows even SMA was like one of the
beginning things and then all the little
guest stars you did and even up to like
Supergirl and Titan or uh Legends of
tomorrow and all these other things you
did it's like you work and you work and
you know that you believe in yourself
and you go I'm bigger than what I'm
being offered I'm bigger than this and
you know it and the people represent you
know it but you're like no you don't
understand it I I I've had those
feelings and then when you suddenly get
validated for me it's it's like it's
almost like your dad who never says any
says hey I'm proud of you it's like it
just validates everything you've been
thinking and it's such it's a beautiful
thing and it's it's welld deserved it is
a thank you but you know what's funny
clowns buddy hack is a beautiful thing I
am you are you're hilarious
um you know the
secret
to getting to that place for
me
was
realizing I am bigger than my career not
in an egotistical way but right I am
more than just my
career I had this we we may have dabbled
in this last time we spoke but I had
this moment of existential crisis where
I had to ask myself honest questions
about who I was and where my identity
lied in my life and at the time it was
in Ambitions it was in material things I
had been making a lot of money and I was
surrounding myself with things that made
me feel like you know created the
illusion of
success um success in the world's eyes
and my career was my
fixation and it was when I
decided
I'm more than my career what if my
career were to disappear tomorrow it
happens to people all the time in our
business you're like what happened to
that guy they were the one they were the
star they were out front and now they're
what like working at Starbucks nothing
wrong with that you know but but like
they disappear from from in front of the
lens and suddenly you're
like what are they worth now you know
um we are much more than our careers we
are so much more than our careers we
sell ourselves so short when we settle
into a job and say like this is who I am
right now and maybe someday you know
maybe we have a dream that someday we'll
be will will have an identity that's a
little bigger a little bigger maybe I'll
be a painter someday I'll have my own
gallery and that's what I'll be we're
more than that we are more than our art
we're more than our our our our highest
Ambitions for our most creative self
like we are I think we Are Spiritual
Beings and that we should be thinking
about like higher minded things you know
that's what love is man it's this thing
that floats above the whole world and
says like how can I actually serve this
place in these people that don't really
want to be served and that don't serve
me you know and when we start thinking
that maybe that's who I am my highest
self is that guy oh so hard to meet that
person so hard to be that person and so
worth struggling to be that and suddenly
I'm not thinking about my career and
when I stop thinking about my career and
thinking about how I can advance myself
it exploded dude it exploded I swear to
God I was like I started doing these
little insta Church videos that were
more for me because they ground me I I
we all know that when you teach a
subject is when you truly know um if you
understand it and it helps you cement
your understanding of it and so for me
it's a practice of like do I know this
subject does it make sense to me can I
explain it to somebody um and also
sharing ideas that I think are fun to
talk about that nobody does because
they're not commercial but um I started
doing that and I I I told my wife before
I posted the first video I said I want
to make sure you're okay with me never
working again in the business like if I
have to be a plumber or something to
make ends me because I have a feeling if
I start posting these videos people are
gonna think I'm some kind of nut job and
I'm never gonna work again and she's
like I'm with you you know and like this
is you being honest and authentic and I
you know I like what you have to say and
go for it you know and so I had her
support and I was like all right I'm
never going to work again and and it was
it was entering this space through that
honest authentic place of like of of ass
shuing an identity that was wrapped in
career that that then the career takes
off it's the most bizarre thing that
life does for us when we let go of what
doesn't matter you know and that that's
been my experience you
know on a on a similar level I I do feel
like you know cuz my whole life I was
you know not my whole life but since
high school theater and college and
plays and Off Broadway and movies and TV
and I got to a certain point where I'm
just like something's
missing I've been CH I've been chasing
this and I've had great success and I'm
very grateful but I'm still empty and
why is that it doesn't make sense like
people look at you you're right that you
know you have a little money you have
nice things you have good friend you
have a career what why what is it and
that's doing the work and that's working
on yourself and which I have
done but also obviously learning to love
yourself which we talk about a lot which
is very difficult because you know if
you grow up not feeling loved and not
feeling like you uh are worthy or good
enough how the hell so you have to stop
and go hey I'm not I can't blame this
anymore what is the issue how do we fix
this and when I started doing things and
this wasn't that long ago I I was I took
a little break from acting for a while
and I did like a little you know like
you know some things but I
thought try doing things that you really
like that you really love doing
passions and all of a sudden in the last
year
to these passions have turned into
things inadvertently oh that's great you
know it's like yeah I always wanted to
write a kids book I and I and I sold it
and it's gonna be out I'm like you know
I really want to do this man you know I
want to do this fun thing and by the way
it's the first time in my
life that the
process is just as fun as the outcome if
not more I'm I'm the process I'm cuz I
used to be like okay 14 hour day to-day
oh what time is it it's okay I only have
6 hours left I only have I am just
enjoying the moment moments and
whether something amazing happens
financially or whatever I'm doing them
because I enjoy them you know I came out
I on the cake yeah it's it's amazing
it's an amazing feeling that's when you
know you're being true to yourself when
you're being true to yourself the
process is the enjoyable part because
the life is the process then life is
working right it feels right because
you're being true to yourself that's um
that's big man it is that's like 50-year
old wisdom right there dude it's taken
me so long and look I have a long way to
go but now and I'm trying to do things
like say no if you just don't want to do
something if it's fear-based that's a
different story but if you don't want to
do it because you're like there's just
not an element of fun in that or there's
not something that that I I can have
passion for then don't do it unless you
have to do it you know to pay the bills
or whatever but I'm starting to just
relax a little more I'm starting to not
get anxious about every [__] thing um
it's look I'm on a I'm on a better path
and because I was on a dark path like
you I hit rock bottom and I went to a
treatment center for three weeks and I I
just started opening up and talking
about life and and it boy did it turn me
around it just it wasn't like holy [__]
but it was like I faced a lot of things
that i' had never faced and that's what
life is life is it's a journey and um I
just I'm I'm happy that I I finally see
the light I finally see in like being
enjoy having uh doing enjoyable things
um that or things that I'm passionate
about so I I it's amazing when you
you're right when you stop
when you stop trying so hard and you
stop thinking that I get this part my
agent's going to be happy everybody's
going to be happy I'm going to be look
at me look at me but then it's then well
now you have to do the work so you're
doing it or who are you doing it for
what are you doing it for admiration
adoration um but when you can do
something and go I want to do this and
I'm probably not going to get any
adoration for this who cares I want to
do this yeah I'm going to make a fart
book
yeah farmor is good we need more I'm
yeah and so I I think that's a beautiful
thing and it's nice to see that you've
you've come around because you've had
more struggles than than most people if
not all the people that I've interviewed
I mean and you also talk openly about
bipolar right I do yeah yeah you know
and uh part you know B bipolar is a
funny thing bipolar is a terrible name
for bipolar what should it be called
it's a terrible name
unipolar unipolar it should be called
unipolar everybody else is
bipolar so if normal healthy people have
an experience throughout the day right
they're um they're coming home from work
they had a decent day at work they work
hard they feel accomplished at driving
home somebody cuts them off in traffic
real bad gives them the finger don't
even understand why I'm going the speed
limit right they feel put off and
they're like how how dare they like
that's so rude people in LA are so rude
they have this feeling that's like
negative towards that experience and
maybe you know opens up feelings of like
insecurity or rage or whatever but
they're still sort of in that place
where they're like but I'm going home oh
well I can shake it off and I'm gonna
they're existing in two places at once
they can exist most people can exist in
two places at once like if [__] happens
they's still some part of themselves
that's
okay with
bipolar you you can I personally cannot
experience two thing two states at once
it is one of the most intense versions
of that experience that you can possibly
imagine so if most people have 99 keys
on the keyboard and the lows are real
low and the highs are real high and they
can enjoy all those right and we can
sort of play in that range for me it
extends as far as the I can see deep
into the Horizon where it curves and
wraps around the edge of the Earth right
those keys still go some of those are so
deep that it's impossible to pull
yourself out of and you need help from a
team of people you need medication right
but I can't possibly experience those
extremes and also do what people tell
you to do go well just think about all
the things you have to be grateful for
play this key up here just play that key
let it pull you out no dude there's no
just playing that key until life stops
hammering That Base tone for me I can't
come out of it and and and there are
times when I have this kind of out-of-
Body Experience when I go
I I should let go of this feeling
like I have to let go of this feeling my
family needs me I need to be present
with my family there's got to be a way
out it's like I'm talking to myself
going like please and it just won't dude
that is bipolar that's bipolar it's
unipol it's you are going to experience
immediately the most intense version of
whatever your experience is and it's
it's authentic and there's no lying
about it it's so complex and deep those
feelings that um I can't act like I I'm
not feeling it and so that's really hard
for people and it's really hard for my
family because like if I'm upset because
of my kid the other day Okay so I've got
three boys they're 11 nine and seven uh
my seven-year-old is just a few days
behind me his birthday so he's about to
be
eight they're very sweet boys I'm so
grateful for them um they're wonderful
young men but they were mad at me
because I told them to go to bed and put
their stuff away the stuff that they
were doing and my littlest said f you
dad I I had had quite a day because I
was out in the countryside for work at a
place with no Wi-Fi and I had press
stuff I was talking to I was talking to
Associated Press and I was talking to
Washington Post all these things that
were supposed to be on camera these
interviews and I couldn't get a signal
dude and it was so frustrating so I'm
dealing with that and then my tells me
to f off because I asked him to go to
bed and I like lose my mind right and I
can't pull myself out of that place to
go like he's just a kid I I experienced
the feeling of a kid telling me to f off
and that feeling took over and there was
nothing else for like an hour and I it
it took me like an hour to finally kind
of like take get off dude it's [__]
the worst it is [__] the worst I
would give anything I would anything to
not be bipolar but yet it's also the
fuel to what I do in my craft I can
experience things as a character because
I can tap into such wide ranging
emotions so deeply and authentically so
fast it's what makes things like Reacher
interesting for you to watch so it's a
blessing and a massive [__] curse
dude I give anything to not be bipolar
wow no one's ever put that in
perspective and I just was that is so
gripping and so so it's I I understand
it's like the [__] just cut me
off I'm going to [__] dude dude could
have a gun come on you're not that guy
you're too old for this [__] I have that
voice you're like no I'm going to go
[__] talk to that he could shoot you
so when you get upset you just kind of
like do do you catch yourself going no
you never talk to me like that again and
then you're yeah you know that's what
you need so so as a Bipolar person I
need resolution I have to have
resolution because I can't just leave
things on the table
like that's why I talk to dude I have so
many hard conversations with the
producers I work with with the creative
teams I work with with Executives at
Studios that I work with like these are
corporate Executives that are not used
to like an actor calling and being like
I need to have an honest conversation
with you about this process this is not
working and let me tell you exactly why
it's making me uh hate life right now
you know and and you s like we need to
find a different process I have to have
those conversations because I cannot be
free of that terrible toxic feeling
that is attached to the anger or
whatever the contempt until we figured
it out like it doesn't just go away it
lives burning hot until you know until
it it until it's figured out you know
until it's figured out and um you know
the highs are the highs are also
dangerous you know it's dangerous to
like live in those highs for too long
you know you start to get you know they
call it delusions of grandeur you know
you start living in this this place
where you start feeling invincible and
making terrible financial decisions or
whatever um because you feel you know
it's dangerous on either side we don't
want to be like we want to be fluid and
and and it makes it very very hard to do
that and so one of the one of the fixes
is having very difficult honest
conversations to find resolution that
doesn't even make sense for most people
they like why do we have to talk about
this let's just let it go yeah I can't
just let it go right let me just ask you
this briefly we can move on but because
this is f just fascinating is it because
no one's put it in perspective like this
um Sean ason talked about his his mother
um and people have talked about it but
no one's ever
really made it like in layman's terms
that really just re resonates with me is
it something someone could tell you hey
you're having an episode or hey you're
being this it's like you you see what
you're doing right now you're a can you
can control this has anyone ever said
that does your wife ever do that yeah
it's usually not like um with such
confidence like hey you're having a
moment right now it's usually a
question are you taking your medication
right now and which also sets me into a
spiral like I hate being asked that you
know um sometimes I've I've not I've
stopped but
um the okay so for for bipolar there is
a list of uh symptoms and uh you are in
an episode usually you know hypomania
mixed episodes are more common um uh but
if you're in an episode uh I think you
have to have four of these coexisting
this Confluence of symptoms happening at
any one time you can be in a bad mood or
you can be irritable or you can have
Reckless suspending or you can be Los
you know you can be kind of having
insomnia all those things that are
telltale signs of mania um they can be
happening I I had a really hard time
sleeping two nights ago and it you know
it's concerning that's a big red flag
man when I stop like when I stop
sleeping for no reason that usually is a
sign that Mania is on the way and um for
it to truly be a manic episode um it has
to be a Confluence of these things so
what we have now is a list that um we I
also have a psychiatrist that gets eyes
on me once a week you know um and that's
a really important thing she can see
sometimes my speech is not it's not the
same it's much quicker or more clipped
or my my ideas or thoughts are much more
yeah you know I'm like hopping lily pads
to different thoughts or ideas and you
know she knows how to see all the sign
she's a bipolar expert so you know yes
um those questions come but usually it's
about like how many other things right
now do we think might be happening one
of the weirdest you want to know one of
the weirdest things that that that is a
symptom for me of um
Mania if I if I wake up one day and like
three pairs of shoes show up from like
Amazon you know like like boxes show up
on my doorstep I know that I'm the we're
well into a mixed episode yeah it is
bizarre dude I have thousands of shoes
and I the other day we've gotten really
good at recognizing oh that's actually
this is Mania I don't even know what
dude I didn't even know I bought shoes
the other day but I woke up I must have
been up at night
transfixed hyperfixation is a thing
right so hyperfixated on shoes bought a
bunch of shoes I woke up and it was like
on my phone right and so I was like
horrified cuz I was like oh God I bought
like three of the same shoes so you
don't even remember
it no I didn't even remember it I only
proof I had was the receipt being open
on my thing and so I told my wife I was
like I think I'm manic and I got my
doctor on the phone and we started
talking about all the other things and
she was like you're for sure into a
mixed episode right now and so we talked
about upping my medication a little bit
I'm on a
bifi um and uh and it helps by the way
what milligram what milligram of that
well I'm super sensitive like like
unusually sensitive to Medicine um so a
little bit affects me like the very
first time I took it it was like an
introductory baby dose and I was like
drooling on myself and I swear I would
never take it again I was like this like
you want to kill me to my wife you want
me dead and she's like no we don't we
just want to help you like I'm never
taking this again and um and then we so
I was like I am never taking that
medicine again to my psychiatrist and we
went like three or four weeks where she
was like okay we'll find
something
um uh I started to have a a real manic
episode and um she was like I think I
just please try it and so I took it
again but during a manic episode and I
was like oh okay I feel totally normal
Now it worked I just took it at the
wrong time and we eased into it that way
um and so it's a small it's a it's one
pill it's one two milligram pill is
enough for me to sort of like like wow
you know and we would increase if things
were like really going haywire would
increase and it was just but since since
since having eyes on this since working
with a psychiatrist who recognizes those
symptoms since reading a million books
and and being very open about it with my
wife um we've learned to see the signs
and it's a language and we started to
speak the language and so when you know
we can approach it in a very um
different way where we go like I think
we actually need to have conversation
about maybe upping the medication right
now and just pulling it in you know I
love it so it's helped a lot I think you
know um I hate the idea of sitting in
front of psychiatrist and being like you
know just she gets her magnifying glass
out and like puts me in her microscope
like I get enough people looking at me
and touching me I walk in this in the
mall and like people are like whispering
and I don't want people looking at me
anymore and I willingly subject myself
to somebody going let me look at your
eyes right now you know I don't want to
do that but you know how important it is
and it's saving my life and it's saving
my marriage it's saving like it's
it's worth it so anybody out there who's
like I don't I don't want to do that
it's long like if my life fell apart
which I could Burn It To The Ground real
easily and I've tried so many times it
would not then then I would be begging
to go back in time and work with a
psychiatrist who puts me on a microscope
for an hour a week you know um I just
want to encourage people who are out
there that maybe have some of the the
trademark symptoms or signs or are in
danger of that kind of thing um before
you burn the house down like you know
just get a team get a team around you
that can can help you recognize these
things and work with it or in general go
go to therapy in general I think therapy
for people in general if you're going
through anything uh you know just having
someone to talk to and balance I've
talked about that a million times all
right this is thank thank you so much
for opening up this is this last 20
minutes is just I'm so engaged that I
could talk to you forever and I'll bug
you in another year when when season 3
yeah
uh this man this is this is so good I
just you know hearing you open up about
this stuff um so Jack Reacher Amazon
Prime December 15th season 2 I got to
watch the first episode and let me tell
you something you're going to love it he
is more
Charming uh there's a new story which I
love a great twist at the end some real
good ass beatings some
heart
you know I have no doubt this is going
to be uh a bigger success than than last
year I'm so proud of you I'm so happy
for you thank you and I'm proud of you
for more more than all the you know
accolades and the jobs and all this that
you're just authentic you and you're
working on on doing all these things I
can see you're always working on being a
better husband a better father a better
friend a better so you know it's giving
giving me this time with you is uh I'm
I'm forever grateful and I appreciate it
I hope you come back and uh thanks man I
yeah I can't wait to I can't wait to do
it again soon man I love talking to you
and uh again grateful to share this
conversation with you um uh in front of
your audience uh it's I'm I I look for
opportunities to open up and it's hard
and uh you've given me one so I'm thank
you all right love you buddy thanks Jack
Reacher December 15th make sure you
watch it I can't wait please
watch love it love him Allan you're a
damn gem I thank you for coming on the
podcast taking your time you're a
machine my my friend you're an honest uh
loyal machine he's jacked he's like a
mountain of a man his arm can fit in my
torso kind of vision visualize that I
don't want to I don't know what that
even means but thank you for being so
humble and open and uh charming and
super
talented so there you go yeah he's a
he's just an awesome guy I mean I I'd
say this is easily top 10 episodes of
all time like him as a guest I mean
definitely and I told you what I love to
is hearing guests talk about previous
appearances and being noted for that
it's not just like hey Allan I loved you
from Blue Mountain State it's like hey I
heard you on inside of you yeah it
really help me like oh that's red yeah I
agree I agree I think it's just
fantastic and uh if you missed out on
all the things I'm saying about the
podcast and all that and what it do just
go to the intro and listen to it it's
very quick and educational and thanks
for listening and again if you like this
episode please follow us and please
support us and listen to more episodes a
lot of times you think you're listening
to One oh I don't know this actor I'm
not going to listen but you learn so
much from different people and it's an
ed there a lot of good ones this year
yeah we've had a great year KN and wood
and thank you Westwood one for all the
hard work and getting us sponsors and um
also keeping us afloat with the patrons
we do appreciate you um Teresa
Britney uh you guys rock I don't think
they're listening but anyway there we go
um now it's time for the top tiers these
are the top tier patrons uh and here we
go patreon.com inside you Nancy D Leah
and Kristen little Lisa Yuko Jill e
Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M
Raj C Joshua D Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal
F Janelle B Mike E Lon Supremo 99 Moore
San Diego M Chad W lean p uh MADD s
Belinda and Dave H Dave Hall I love my
Dave Hall Sheil G brat d Ray har sabath
T tomman to m bety d ran C Cory K Dev
Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D Joey
M Eugene and Leah
Corey Angela F Mel s Christine s go
ahead read a couple Eric H Shane R
Andrew M Amanda R Kevin e Stephanie K
jorel jam and J lean J Luna R Mike F
Stone H Brian L Jules M Kendall LOL
Jessica B lowercase Kyle F Marisol P Kye
J Brian a good Ashley F Maran Luis l
Romeo the band Frank B Jen T Nikki L
April R Randy s
jdw oral P remember that toothbrush Oral
P yeah but I've never seen this name
before oral oral oral P maybe it's oral
oral
oral okay Ginger somniac Rachel D
Melissa H Nick W Stephanie and Evan
Charlene a Don G and J Benny B we love
you that's for
sure um thank you guys I appreciate you
more than you know um so for Michael
Rosel I'm here in the Hollywood Hills of
Hollywood California I'm Bryce it's just
Bryce baby in the same place obviously
you are Little Wave to the camera we
love you thanks for listening and uh big
episode coming up next week you do not
want to miss it if you like movies like
The Matrix if you like movies like Bill
and Ted if you like a movie called Sweet
November that I was in with him this
person and his band's here too so you
might want to stick around be good to
yourself we'll see you next
[Music]
week